these in their mid there how nice are
you I'm too kind I I could do I could do
a lot of damage out here I promise you
that I see some of those coming and I'm
like
I know exactly what to say to this girl
but you know what I'm gonna get Jose
over there I'm gonna let him do the
process because I'm gonna I don't want
to lose ship either so what's the point
you know hide your wife
they've got to have ethics guys you've
got to have ethics that's that's what
separates us from animals you are the
man of the people thank you thank you so
any anyone any other questions from no
but you get a nice off of that she has a
blessing the gym leader Mike
um I had a question you gotta talking
you got to talk into your mic I need to
remember it now
I feel like cat has a lot to say was it
was it something about me give us
something no give us some sauce me
attracting damaged women no nothing
about that but you are like you know
exposing yourself right now yeah nothing
good about that I'm still gonna win it's
fine
how long have you been doing this
um well this is just like it's an
evolving framework
um just to be honest with you like every
woman is kind of different they're like
different kind of narcissists some of
them take part in their body some of
them take buys and how much they can get
oh man some of them take pride in all
sorts of things so you gotta there's no
kind of shortcut to like taking people
as they are and trying to understand
where you fit uh but this first stage
never never do you sometimes look at
Psychology I I well look at Psychology
like look into it do some research then
you're fully equipped yeah yeah 100 you
know what this is really that first
stage number one that is psychology
Baxter yeah
he is studying right now yeah it's just
like being being conscious in it and
understand I've what I started out with
was just talking to women generically
hey you know you're pretty cute let's do
this let's do that
um and I noticed that when I was way too
direct and honest people you know didn't
reciprocate but when I ignore people
once in a while they thought that meant
I had greater value so that's what I did
right it happened naturally because I
have a good job so as my time gets taken
up I I don't have the time and that that
kind of fit in wow it worked and every
time I gave someone too much attention
the resort showed me that actually this
stage is really [ __ ] important you
cannot be constantly available because
what's she gonna think right you met
this guy he's attracted to me and he's
giving me all this attention for free
why would I spend more time engaging
with this person
gaslighting right women hate certainty
if you say to someone I love you you're
great we should get married you're great
that's boring in it what you say is
you're kind of cute and kind of see
something working out but I see a flame
in you or some [ __ ] like that that
doesn't mean anything right and Friends
eventually she will kind of piece that
step together by herself but I can't
tell you what to think I can just like
show you possibilities but make make
kind of no mistakes I'm not kind of
manipulating anyone here women are
manipulating themselves listen I'm just
saying I'm just saying I say very little
in this stage she doesn't know who I am
she doesn't know where I'm from she
doesn't know my childhood traumas or
anything like that because I have no
traumas yeah they they call it the
push-pull theory oh yeah that's true
yeah there's no push pulling though
because this is a framework for a high
value person so
have you people that are in this
framework are extremely dispensable look
with that fighter to Alpha that is
technically push and pull because yeah
because you're pushing in the beta stage
you're giving more validation and
attention than required and then you
pull it away confuses the [ __ ] out of
them you then give them that mystery and
that's when they worry about you the
beta is not is actually a pool because
modern women are feminists are the
narcissists so they tend to think that
like let's bear in mind you're
pretending beta yeah I mean I give them
what they clearly want in it you so so
you're dating me you think this guy is
awesome he's got everything what do I
have to offer
um just sex really but I have to
convince you that there's something else
that you're really interesting and
fascinating that I can't go like more
than a day without speaking to you so
you know I kind of have these
conversations
um and if you stimulate someone in the
right way they will project how they
want to feel unto you you just you just
got to keep on saying General things yes
see I wouldn't class that as bait I
think I'll just I'll just classic is
giving me attention and validation
letting them think that they've got you
where they want you and then you remove
it you pull it and that's when you leave
because you're intentionally doing that
it's strategic and then you pull it away
this is basic pickup dating coach
I'm not saying I'm not acting but to me
this is all the professional this is
just a professional kind of a process
for me are you hold on are you are you
learning about men yeah I'm learning
that is the time I've blocked a guy I
was right that's what I'm learning
you're going to be single anyway
I love being single I don't need to be
rude that's not rude it's not bad I love
it she's got infinite advice okay good
yeah I don't think there are many men
that could match up to you just because
okay absolutely amazing you are
generally like from what you've said
you'll be better off marrying yourself
because that would be an awesome I've
seen this framework in real time right
now in real time you are so insightful
in the way you value yourself I respect
our respect your boundaries
um text me I might ignore you in other
words
and I might just block you boo in other
words do it in other words you better
have that top-notch [ __ ] dildo yeah
I think I think Jess had a question
um it's not a question you guys said
something about
um you can't make women think what they
want to think and I would say that the
first stage as interesting as it may be
where you don't say much you say little
as to anything possible and you just
have them speak
essentially I would think that would be
valuable for a woman to do because if
you're saying all this stuff women do
take things you could say no I don't
relationship and women were taking well
he doesn't want a relationship right now
but maybe in the near future he'll want
it and it's
it's interesting and like crazy but I
can understand it as well as like the
first stage as you don't say much to
help them understand like this is what I
actually want this stage is all about
kind of tension it's all about kind of
um you're creating tension and removing
tension yeah yeah but
I'm at this level now where me removing
tension is just like me just not
bothering it's like when I remove my
time and attention that's that's where
like you know because women women know
who the high level guys are like there's
not enough time around you they know
because I come across as goofy initially
because I do that on purpose because I
don't want any Cloud Chasers because
they're long they're long you know you
guys are coming with your shiny belt
you're attracting the most annoying kind
of women for me I want someone who's
intelligent and who generally wants to
mess around and we kind of do this and
women who can maintain themselves and
maintain their own emotional state you
know the kind of sense of being
naturally do this the other day the
mature woman who was texting you
constantly
you never date a mature woman who was
like too dominant or too submissive
didn't actually do that because they
have to function as adults I like adults
that's what I like you know
um occasionally some young ones but she
has to be very smart this strategy which
is a strategy
though yeah though you may have come to
this strategy yourself this strategy is
actually just a standard pickup strategy
it's just common sense it is
and the key thing is guys the women in
this stage are extremely dispensable and
I'll tell you why women think you are
extremely dispensable if you meet
someone even vaguely attractive she's
got tons of guys talking to her all the
time if you're the top 10 of guys maybe
you're the top one percent or no point
one percent like me right maybe you go
into a club and you can find a
relatively attractive girl and get a
number and you know that's nothing
compared to what the average woman can
get a woman who looks like a foot can go
to a club
so let me ask you a question so she
doesn't that's why she can drop you
quickly all women think you're
dispensable so I don't know why some
guys out here putting their heart on the
line like oh she rejected me bro
why are you talking to one person as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible